vous allez entendre effectivement un
débat avec christophe sirugue du ps et
sandrine mois de la cgt jean baptiste
lemoyne ump benoît bellot de la cgpme un
mot justement benoît vidaud je vous
demande à tous d'être bref parce que ça
va passer très vite la deuxième partie
sur cette représentation parce qu'on a
évoqué mais très rapidement donc des 4 5
millions de salariés des tpe des très
petites entreprises pourquoi la cgpme et
elle contre françois rebsamen dit il n'y
a pas de raison que les peulhs et
salariés des toutes petites entreprises
ne sont pas représentés pour parce que
pour nous le dialogue social existe des
jeunes naturellement il n'y a pas besoin
de créer une instance régionale pour
qu'aujourd'hui on rajoute une contrainte
de plus parce que sans études même si
elle est régionale nous on était on
était sûr sur une position qui était de
ne pas instaurer du tout de
représentativité dans les moins de 11
puisque pour nous il ne se justifie pas
aujourd'hui dans ces petites entreprises
on a d'autres soucis à régler dans les
petites entreprises que de lörrach
rejeté cette contrainte on contracte non
c'est pas une contrainte je pense que
qu'il y ait un dialogue dans
l'entreprise dans les tpe personne ne le
conteste mais avoir un dialogue c'est
pas la même chose que d'avoir des
représentants des salariés qui peuvent
porter des problématiques spécifiques et
elle existe aussi dans les tpe et il n'y
a aucune raison que les 4,6 millions de
salariés qui sont les tpe n'est pas
d'organisation représentative pour cela
donc nous mettons en place ces
commissions régionales 10 salariés pour
une grande région bourgogne franche
comté on va peut-être arriver à trouver
dix salariés je suis pas sûr que ça des
structures l'organisation des tpe dans
ce pays donc à un moment dix salariés
dix représentants des chefs d'entreprise
qui permettront d'évoquer là aussi les
points essentiels pour faire avancer à
la fois le monde de l'entreprise à la
fois le droit des salariés je ne crois
pas que ce qui me semble est une vraie
avancée pourquoi 4,6 millions servier
n'étaient pas couverts ce qui est une
vraie avancée puisse être considérée
comme une remise en cause du dialogue
qui par ailleurs peut tout à fait se
poursuivre à l'intérieur des tpe bien
évidement un petit mot bien évidemment
oui nous je suis tout à fait d'accord et
il est assez extraordinaire que
l'ensemble des salariés n'est pas les
mêmes droits selon la taille de
l'entreprise comme si des citoyens
n'auraient pas les mêmes droits selon la
région dans lesquels dorment dans
laquelle il habite c'est assez
incroyable et sur le fait que le
dialogue social bien évidemment dans les
tpe dialogue social doit exister il est
pas uniforme pour preuve les conseillers
du salarié qui assiste les salariés qui
sont dans les années qui sont les
entreprises et a pas de représentant du
personnel venait à la bourse du travail
sur ces salariés qui sont obligés
d'avoir recours aux conseillers du
salarié parce que pas de feuille de paye
pas d'heures supplémentaires de payer
quel recours ils ont pour maman et bien
je pense que c'est le temps pour eux
d'avoir dix représentants du personnel
jean-baptiste lemoyne mais je crois que
en fait au delà du dispositif qui est
dans le projet de loi et dont je vois
effectivement qu'il est circonscrit à ce
stade je crois que la crainte la crainte
c'est que à terme on sait qu'un
législateur succède à l'autre qui a des
effets de cliquer à terme les pouvoirs
de ces commissions change de nature
d'ailleurs la cfdt l'a dit dans le
communiqué de monsieur bergé en disant
nous souhaitons que ces commissions et
des poires de médiation dès lors qu'on
mêle douala dans la médiation ça veut
dire que oui il va y avoir une ingérence
peut-être à terme entre eux et bien
les dirigeants de l'entreprise c'est ça
les salariés et c'est donc les craintes
elles sont là voilà et je pense que à
force effectivement de créer un
environnement qui qui décourage un petit
peu ce qu'ils ont envie de créer on crée
en craie du coup du coup
une différence non pas entre salariés
mais entre ceux qui ont un job et c'est
qu'ils n'ont pas parce que le problème
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on a un marché du
travail qui est considérablement
fragmenté entre d'un côté des gens qui
ont un emploi souvent plus tôt en cdi
et des gens qui sont qui enchaîne les
cdd qui enchaîne d intérim etc et qui
n'arrive pas à stabiliser leur situation
justement parce que eh bien il ya des
gens qui ont qui n'ose pas leur proposer
des situations plus pérenne contenu de
toutes les contraintes que ça su que ça
malheureusement génère donc c'est là où
vraiment notre modèle il faut peut-être
l'adapter dans un souci d'être beaucoup
plus inclusif et éviter ces personnes
qui malheureusement sont en dehors du
marché du travail voilà rapidement
marqué ce qu on a beaucoup parlé j'ai
entendu amont mais c'est symptomatique
ingérence ingérence comme si les
représentants du personnel
comme si ceux qui sont élus pour eelv
extérieur l'entreprise madame un peu
plus ailleurs mais ce courrier on
pourrait faire autrement mais il serait
la capacité de pouvoir informer et d
consulter proposé avec les les salariés
comme ça se fait dans d'autres
entreprises pouvoir proposer des
stratégies également pourquoi n'y
aurait-il pas droit pourquoi le
représentant du salarié dans la petite
entreprise en ferait des propositions
contraires à la pérennité de
l'entreprise ce n'est pas le cas il veut
effectivement c'est l'entreprise perdure
avec les salari dedans avec tous les os
coeur l'a bien compris et largué dans
des arrivées ce que veut dire c'est que
j'ai pas dis ça je dis qu'une personne
qui externes à l'entreprise forcément
elle vit pas la réalité de l'entreprise
les enquêtes là où il ya des craintes on
a bien compris les arguments des uns et
des autres le compte personnel
d'activité
il est prévu aussi par ce texte françois
hollande a dit dimanche que ce serait la
grande réforme sociale du quinquennat en
gros alors ce serait un ponte avis si
j'ai bien compris regroupant ces
débilités la formation le compte épargne
temps les droits au chômage / chargeable
la mutuelle enfin bref quel intérêt
l'intérêt c'est qu'aujourd'hui chaque
actif à des droits individuels qui le
acquiert au cours de son parcours
professionnel
la question de savoir comment ces droits
acquis d'abord son portable d'une
entreprise à une autre parce qu'on sait
malheureusement conflit l'entreprise
toute sa vie professionnelle dans la
même entreprise donc cette portabilité
des droits est un élément indispensable
sur lequel il faut dialoguer et le
deuxième élément c'est la fongibilité
des droits des droits acquis à la
formation au titre par exemple de divers
de différent que de divers comptes il
faut qu'on puisse imaginer comment ces
droits sont fongible selon le moment où
le salarié peut en avoir besoin bien
évidemment inspectant l'entreprise qui
derrière doit à s'assurer que ces temps
de formation sont compatibles avec le
fonctionnement de l'entreprise donc ce
qu'on individuel d'activité il regroupe
tous ces éléments là il va être mis en
place dans le cadre de ce projet de loi
son fonctionnement les modalités sont
renvoyés l'encore aux partenaires
sociaux partenaires sociaux qui avant le
mois de décembre devront essayer de voir
comment tout cela peut fonctionner ça me
paraît là aussi une avancée importante
pour une nouvelle loi en 2016 est une
application 2017 vous êtes
passé on est prêt à discuter en dehors
du conte pénibilité sur lequel qui est
appliqué à bien des gens aujourd'hui
donc il ya plus de débat ça c'est très
serré oui je fais partie de ce grand de
ce grand chérissent aussi d'ailleurs y a
plus grand chose à travailler
aujourd'hui vous savez les quatre points
sont applicables et les six l'année
prochaine donc voilà c'est encore
simplification ça s'appelait je crois le
projet de loi simplification pour
l'entrepreneur sa mourir de rire mais
bon c'est à mourir de rire et jamais sur
le contour y est il et je vais en faire
une petit bien dialogue que je peux
avoir y compris avec votre organisation
au niveau national laisse à penser que
healy a matière à préserver les
principes de ce compte individuel
pénibilité et en même temps à simplifier
véritablement rendez vous fin juin je
rendrai mettra vos manettes de jeu
terminal des comptes personnels avec le
compte personnel oui on va on va
travailler puisque c'est quelque chose
qui va dans la simplification qui va
dans le bon sens parce que je disais
tout à l'heure il n'y a pas que des
mauvaises choses qui va dans le bon sens
et qui va nous permettre d'avoir
peut-être quelque chose d'unique
poursuivre notre salariés sont livrés
son livre est finalement son livre est
unique de 20 heures 115 santé ce qui
regroupe des coups de poing je ne
repartirai pas de la pénibilité c'est
promis
c'est s'il ya une proposition de la cgt
qui l'on travaille depuis longtemps
c'est ce qu'on appelle nous le nouveau
statut du travail salarié et la sécurité
sociale professionnelle c'est à dire que
le constat comme l'avait dit le salarié
change souvent d'entreprises mais à
chaque fois qu'il change d'entreprise et
perd tous ses droits y compris le
salaire il repart à zéro donc son
expérience sa qualification n'est pas
reconnue donc pour nous c'est une c'est
une proposition qui est une bonne entame
qui va dans le bon sens allait bien
évidemment pas suffisante nous on veut
effectivement un ensemble de droits y
compris salaires la reconnaissance des
qualifications que le salarié garde et
qu'ils gardent quand ils chantent des
chants d'entreprise et qui est opposable
également à l'employeur des garanties
individuelles et collectives en
changement d'entreprise ça c'est
important pour que le salarié est une
réelle progression tout au long de sa
carrière de salaire et de reconnaissance
de ces qualifications de son expérience
professionnelle
quelque chose qui nous soutiennent non
mais ce que je sais que l'idée d'avoir
finalement on part souvent guichet
unique de simplification d'avoir voilà
un moniteur pour réunir des droits ça se
regarde bien sûr maintenant dans le
détail y'a quoi ya justement tout ce qui
est lié aux comptes formation également
qui est dedans il ya la pénibilité sa
connection tout ça mais quand on prend
dans le détail un par un sur la
formation professionnelle cette loi qui
aussi était vantée comme étant la grande
loi le grand accord etc pardon mais
aujourd'hui les entreprises
d'information et puis toute la filière
de formation tire la sonnette d'alarmé
en disant il y en a un sur 23 millions
qui a pu bénéficier pour l'instant du
cpf alors il ya le système est quand
même emboliser la réforme a été mal
conçu et donc c'est un vrai sujet et
puis le gros problème aussi quand on
parle de formation c'est que les tpe les
pme aujourd'hui vont avoir des
formations obligatoires de sécurité etc
maintenant ne sont plus éligibles la
formation professionnelle donc elles
vont devoir payer c'est un coup
supplémentaire donc on voit bien que mon
problème avec tout ça c'est que y'a des
grandes annonces on crie formation
professionnelle compte pénibilité et
c'est donc au caire c'est bien entendre
mais dans la vraie vie sur le terrain
est bien souvent il ya loin de la coupe
aux lèvres et on se retrouve dans des
situations
d'urgence parce qu'on a des entrepôts
des entreprises qui ne savent pas
financé et bien le retrait de l'état en
matière justement deux formations
obligatoires ou par exemple sur le conte
pénibilité clairement je veux dire c'est
financé par une cotisation
supplémentaire donc moi ce que je veux
dire c'est que très bien pour les grands
concepts may hamm et athlon neo aussi à
regarder sur le terrain ce que ça donne
et là je crois que malheureusement
valide émis des messages un peu de
détresse clair les contours et modalités
c'est encore flou est un élément
important sur l'afpa jeudi
l'association de formation
professionnelle je dis à mon collègue de
l'ump que un moment faut quand même
faire attention à ce que l'on dit quand
on sait comment le gouvernement que vous
avez soutenu a mis à mal l'afpa qui l'a
mis dans une situation intenable
notamment par des restrictions
budgétaires considérables aujourd'hui il
faut réhabiliter l'afp à l'installer
dans le service public de l'emploi comme
étant un vrai interlocuteur repréciser
ses missions c'est ce qui va être fait
d'ailleurs dans le cadre de ce projet de
loi et je pense que parler de la
formation professionnelle
c'est aussi reconnaître qu'il ya des
acteurs importants c'est aussi faire le
point ce ver gaspésie un vrai sujet
c'est aussi passera sur les dispositifs
qui marchent pas c'est le cas du contrat
nouvelle chance qui est aussi dans ce
texte là c'est à dire qu'il va permettre
de prolonger leur contrat le contrat de
professionnalisation pour les chômeurs
de longue durée donc je pense qu'il ya
dans ce texte un élément qui là aussi
sur la formation professionnelle vont
permettre de corriger des erreurs qui
ont été faites et pas que celle d'un
dispositif que vous avez évoquées mais
aussi les sacrifices qui ont été faits
sur ne lave pas pour permettre
d'accompagner des demandeurs d'emploi ou
des arrêts du salarié qui ont besoin de
cette formation sans
gp revenir comme je vais je vais revenir
sur la situation précédente sur un
exemple qui interpelle parmi d'autres
sur l'abeille noire est donné sur la
jeunesse sur les négociations égalité
femmes-hommes je pense que c'était un
grand projet du gouvernement
on voit que sur les murs l'égalité en
continuant à l'égalité salariale n'est
toujours pas là pour autant il y à une
négociation annuelle obligatoire sur
l'égalité femmes-hommes elle disparaît
c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné les
entreprises et chef d'entreprise devait
proposer un rapport de situation
comparée c'est à dire une liszt une
analyse statistique
justement qui permettait une négociation
sur le rattrapage des pertes de salaires
des femmes par rapport aux hommes et
elle disparaît pourquoi est-ce que cela
va dans le bon sens là on va y perdre
notamment parce que ça concerne la
moitié de la population et on sait quand
on
vous permet c'est inexact simplement
parce que c'était écrit dans la loi
entre parenthèses dans les attributions
du troisième élément de négociation sur
les conditions de travail égalité
professionnelle hommes-femmes s'est
inscrit dans le débat cette moyenne
négociations ne pouvait pas l'être alors
naturellement votre
info christophe sirugue inscrit un texte
va pouvoir évoluer à l'assemblée
nationale sur escaut bien pouvoir faire
évoluer et nous aussi à l'assemblée
travers les députés justement c'est ce
que j'allais vous poser comme question
avec celle de bruno les syndicats dont
ils organisent une action contre cette
loi ou est-ce que vous rencontrez vous
allez pousser une action va déjà
interpellé les députés dans l'ensemble
des départements sur ce qui touche
effectivement ce projet de loi est là on
voudrait le faire évoluer bien
évidemment une action ne sais pas mais
déjà interpellé les députés pour qu'ils
connaissent vraiment et les saynètes les
propositions et les sénateurs bien
évidemment les samoa vraiment les
propositions des organisations
syndicales et les dangers là et c'est
reconnaître les propositions de la cgt
qui n'ont pas été reprises pour partie
dans le projet de loi
conclusion m e vélo mais attendez oui je
suis dubitatif parce qu'effectivement
nous le principal point sur lequel on
voudrait s'exprimer au delà du guichet
unique du compte de la fille chante et
ça va dans le bon sens donc on va pas
faire de la polémique pour créer de la
polémique inutile c'est quelque chose
auquel on participera dans les travaux
et négociations avec avec les syndicats
de salariés
la seule chose dont on voulait parler de
vraiment très fortement que c'est pas
l'objet aujourd'hui c'est la pénibilité
à la soirée à regarder la pénibilité
s'est elle fait parvenir hier c'est le
projet de loi va passer à l'assemblée
nationale de la femme est ensuite ce
sera chez vous au sénat un vote en
deuxième lecture en juillet pour
l'instant large de perles de cette
émission merci à tous d'avoir accepté
notre invitation je vous rappelle que
vous pouvez revoir cette émission sur
internet la semaine prochaine il sera
question d'immigration en raison bien
sûr des drames que vivent les immigrés
en méditerranée pour l'heure le 12/13 se
poursuit avec le développement de
l'actualité nationale
à bientôt
on